quand je suis dans une voiture je ne
peux pas dire j'aime ou j'aime pas la
voiture la voiture est nécessaire dans
un procès quand les médiums posent des
questions je leur réponds cette espèce
de miroir aux alouettes que les
journalistes tendent aux avocats ne
m'intéressent pas du tout
quand vous avez un peu l'habitude des
médias vous essayez de faire court
essayer de faire choque moi j'ai
confiance dans votre justice s'il parle
à la télévision comme mon plaide il va
être ridicule il y a très très bon
avocats là-bas qui sont du lissime
devant la caméra et l'inverse
ils adorent se montrer ce sont des
coques il parle d'abord dans l'intérêt
de leurs clients en tout cas c'est ce
qu'ils disent toujours et parfois il
faut bien reconnaître aussi que les
avocats parlent tout simplement parce
qu'ils aiment bien parler c'est clair
qu'il y a des avocats qui commencent par
chercher où sont les caméras avant de
s'exprimer quoi de la mesure où les
avocats ont tellement un ego déjà
développé il finit par s'alimenter
définitivement dans les médias une fois
un avocat savait qu'il était passé à la
télévision il est devenu s'acheter une
robe exprès pour ça l'avocat ne doit pas
utiliser les médias pour faire un show
pour se faire la publicité la
médiatisation ne peut pas faire de mal à
un cabinet et à son chiffre d'affaires
ou alors ça sera désespérant à quoi
servent les médias et les journalistes
dans ce cas là la médiatisation a
sûrement une certaine influence sur le
cours du procès mais quelle influence
c'est l'affaire qui fait l'avocat et non
pas l'avocat qui fait la faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il y a 100 ans condamné un jeune
officier
qui avait le temps d'être Juifs
aujourd'hui on condamne aux jardiniers
parce qu'il a le tort d'être maghrébin
robe noire voit de Centaure regard dur
les avocats impressionnent citoyens à
part dernier rempart des libertés
publiques ils sont aussi de formidables
machines à communiquer est-ce que
vous-même avocat vous avez pas été un
petit peu sur internet à la radio et à
la télévision ils savent occuper
l'espace médiatique en maniant l'art de
l'éloquence de leur côté les médias se
délectent de ces stars faussement
modestes
alors pourquoi les journalistes sont-ils
si friands de leurs bons mots pourquoi
les avocats se pressent-ils devant leur
caméra et leur micro
quels sont leurs stratégies médiatiques
la publicité est officiellement
interdite alors défense de leurs clients
ou pub déguisées
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
27 janvier 2010 Palais de justice de
Paris une foule de par an et d'amis se
pressent devant la Chambre de la Cour
d'appel pour assister à la prestation de
serment d'une cinquantaine de jeunes
avocats
ce qui est inhabituel c'est la présence
massive de micro et de caméra la raison
de cette affluence c'est une
personnalité qui va endosser la robe
d'avocat aujourd'hui
pour une fois l'ancienne ministre semble
ne pas vouloir dévoiler sa dernière robe
à la presse
qui devait être une fête vire à la foire
d'empoigne
photographe des caméras mènes sont
refoulées par les gendarmes
elle est déjà partie à Missa direct
Eric Hadj et photographe de presse on
peut dire que c'est elle en se faufilant
il a réussi à prendre quelques clichés
du serment de l'ex ministre quand on
était un personnage public on peut
continuer à l'être même après on se sert
pas de la presse avant et enfin quand on
quand on veut
se servir des médias une vieille
habitude qui n'appartient pas seulement
à Rachida Dati
[Applaudissements]
dès l'apparition de la presse les hommes
de l'oie ont su ce médiatiser l'image de
l'avocat apparaît véritablement au
milieu du 19e siècle avec l'essor des
gazettes judiciaires
la figure de l'avocat devient très vite
incontournable une représentation très
contrastée à charge et à décharge les
caricaturistes de l'époque le
représentent parfois comme un héros
désintéressé défenseur de la veuve et de
l'orphelin mais souvent aussi comme un
homme cupide qui flou ses clients pire
encore il apparaît parfois comme un
incompétent notoire
[Musique]
jusqu'aux années 50 le public se
passionne pour les grands procès et
découvre les ténors du barreau des
hommes dont l'éloquence fascine les
foules
[Musique]
à la fin des années 60 ses grands
avocats prennent leur retraite
une époque se termine
[Musique]
disparaître quasiment cette figure de
l'avocat puisque la génération qui suit
n'est pas encore ne s'impose pas ne
parvient pas à s'imposer c'est encore
trop jeunes il y a pas de véritablement
de grands procès à l'époque à partir de
1954 après les excès du procès Dominici
caméra microé appareil photo sont
interdits de séjour dans les prétoirs
les avocats perdent de leur superbe
alors pour relater leur plaidoirie les
chroniqueurs judiciaires prennent du
gallon et parmi eux un personnage haut
en couleur Frédéric potcher le créateur
du reportage judiciaire à la télévision
c'est Frédéric patcher Frédéric pas cher
il avait besoin d'aucune image Frédéric
potcher il se campait plein champ en
face de la caméra et nous avions un
numéro extraordinaire de 10 minutes qui
m'y met l'audience qui s'expliquait
qu'il vivait qu'il a revivait alors la
j'affirme que Monsieur Taron c'est tout
maître Vizzavona lui aussi adjure léger
de dire la vérité et comme légèreté
alors l'audience reprend son cours
normal merci Frédéric en tout cas
un géant quand je j'étais intimidé comme
un gamin devant le Père Noël médiatique
j'étais fasciné au début des années 70
une nouvelle génération d'avocats prend
le pouvoir arrive sur la scène
médiatique c'est Robert Badinter Thierry
Lévy Paul Lombard également pour
défendre des causes qu'ils estiment
importante faire avancer faire
progresser la société l'idée de l'avocat
qui fait avancer qui a un rôle
démocratique très fort joue beaucoup
dans ces années 70
les années 70 c'est l'époque où le débat
sur la peine de mort secoue la société
française les abolitionnistes les plus
en vue comprennent que la télévision
peut servir leur cause Robert baninter
sur si l'ambassade et regard ombrageux
sort de l'anonymat de son cabinet pour
s'exposer devant les caméras il devient
l'emblème de la lutte contre la
guillotine vous avez été un avocat
médiatique qu'est-ce qu'il fait
et vous avez été un grand
avocats
j'ai connu des avocats
admirable
personne ne les a connu
mais personne ne les connaissait j'ai
connu des avocats célèbres c'est pas la
taille grand ou petit
dont la réputation était à mon sens au
moyen
actif
entre la réputation la notoriété et la
capacité il n'y a pas identité
devenu garde des sceaux en 1981 du haut
de la tribune de l'Assemblée nationale
il prononce un discours en forme de
plaidoirie
grâce à vous
la justice française
ne sera plus une justice qui tue de tout
mon coeur je vous remercie sous l'oeil
des caméras de télévision la peine de
mort est abolie Robert Badinter vient
d'entrer dans l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui le grand public est devenu
familier des Dupont-Moretti Colin ou
spinner une génération d'avocats qui a
grandi avec la télévision et on connaît
tous les ressorts
Eric Dupont-Moretti grosse voix et
carure de rugbyman l'avocat pénaliste
surnommé Akita Tor et devenu en quelques
années une star des barreaux puis des
médias
[Musique]
aujourd'hui vous avez plus besoin des
médias vous êtes extrêmement connus
d'ailleurs je m'en vais
[Rires]
d'ailleurs je me casse non vous avez
raison
mais non mais besoin des médias il y a
aussi l'intérêt que l'on peut tirer dans
une affaire de la médiatisation
il y a l'intérêt personnel que on parle
de la médiatisation de l'avocat mais
c'est pas ce qui est important même si
si pour l'avocat c'est pas une
contingence subalterne ce qui est
important c'est qu'on peut en tirer pour
le client
pour celui qu'on défend dans un quartier
populaire l'avocat lillois crève
véritablement les écrans au moment de
l'affaire d'Outreau je vous rappelle
quand même qu'il y a un homme qui
s'appelle Mourmand qui est présumé
innocent non plus à vie mais à mort et
que cet homme s'est suicidé et je pense
que il y a des gens qui doivent un peu
regarder vers le ciel
[Musique]
Pascal Robert Diard et chroniqueuse
judiciaire au journal Le Monde elle
connaît bien l'homme pour l'avoir suivi
sur de nombreuses affaires
[Musique]
au sens où c'est vraiment le côté
musical quoi c'est ça qui m'a il fait
des tournées Dupont-Moretti
Dupont-Moretti il va pas aller en palais
être procès en procès pour plaider ouais
c'est vraiment un plaideur et donc il
est toujours intéressant à regarder et à
écouter d'ailleurs parce qu'elle est
deux parce qu'il y a une espèce de
présence physique qui est très très
forte et puis il y a une manière de de
prendre le pouvoir de prendre le pouvoir
sur l'audience de prendre le pouvoir sur
les jurés d'aller les chercher de de
convaincre il y a une violence en lui il
y a oui c'est un spectacle c'est un vrai
spectacle
de mots deux mots d'abord monsieur le
Président messieurs de la cour Mesdames
et Messieurs les jurés
deux mots que jamais je n'aurais
envisagé de prononcer
si ce matin je n'avais pas fait l'objet
des attaques
inadmissibles
de Monsieur l'avocat général bon que
vous n'ayez pas les avocats médiatiques
en équipe je vous aime pas non plus
Eric Dupond-Moretti aux assises un
document exceptionnel du réalisateur
Olivier piggetti à Montpellier l'avocat
défend Fabrice Cusain accusé d'avoir
braqué une banque avec un bulldozer
l'avocat général vient de requérir à son
encontre une peine de 18 ans de
réclusion criminelle
nous avons le même âge que
moi je pourrais le traiter avec la
condescendance des bourgeois en disant
mais ce type finalement c'est qu'un
délinquant
un sale mec
je peux aussi me dire mais
si j'avais vécu ce qu'il a vécu
qu'est-ce que je serais devenu
et il faut pas avoir fait l'École
nationale de la magistrature pour
comprendre ça
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas mesdames et
messieurs le fruit de votre histoire pas
que cela évidemment
mais aussi ça
il y a un des deux gendarmes qui m'a
filé une photo de Cuzin quand il avait
20 ans
avec des cheveux
vous avez eu des cheveux
et on voit il suffit de la voir la photo
que c'est un gamin
c'est un gamin qui est malheureux
pour une fois Éric Dupont-Moretti n'a
pas réussi à convaincre les juré Fabrice
Cuzin et copra de 14 ans de prison
[Musique]
sa naissance médiatique Éric
Dupont-Moretti la doit à cet homme
Michel marie journaliste depuis 32 ans à
l'hebdomadaire Le nouveau détective leur
première rencontre remonte à 1985 à
l'époque le jeune avocat cherche surtout
à se faire connaître
un matin je reçois un coup de téléphone
d'un avocat un vocal Lillois qui
s'appelait Eric Dupond-Moretti qui m'a
dit voilà j'ai un dossier qui pourrait
vous intéresser il avait une bonne voie
et je lui dis écoutez si vous avez
l'occasion de passer à Paris venez me
voir je suis à Levallois-Perret et
contre toute attente le lendemain à midi
moins le quart le téléphone sonne sur
mon bureau et il me dit voilà c'est
mettre Dupont-Moretti je suis à Paris en
fait j'étais venu exprès exactement
et bon il est pas quand il était pas
comme aujourd'hui il était un peu plus
mince un peu plus un peu plus dangereux
c'est la réécriture de l'histoire puis
et puis voilà puis on est devenu très
copain dans un premier temps et puis ami
ensuite voilà puis j'éviter aussi que
son journal pour dire la vérité était un
journal très lu en prison on lit plus
détectives qu'on ne lit une journal Le
Monde en tôle voilà et alors bon Michel
évidemment
quand j'avais le contact je l'ai appelé
pour un certain nombre de dossiers je
plaidais il est venu et effectivement il
est il est l'auteur d'un des premiers
papiers me concernant
[Musique]
en 25 ans de barreaux l'avocat est
devenu le champion incontesté du nombre
d'acquittement
il vient dans totaliser 90
j'en suis à la fois très fier et à la
fois je m'en défie parce que je veux pas
que les gens qui me désignent pensent
que
l'avocat est un magicien j'ai mon lot
d'échecs et il est extrêmement important
bien sûr que j'ai cette comptabilité
mais on en a fait quelque chose que je
ne voulais pas mais maintenant c'est
aussi le risque de la médiatisation on
maîtrise évidemment pas tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors communiquer ou ne pas communiquer
avec la presse chaque avocat a sa propre
stratégie mais rares sont ceux qui
refusent de s'exprimer sur les dossiers
qu'ils ont à défendre
Jean-Marie Charron chercheur en
sociologie des médias au CNRS connaît
bien les liaisons troubles qui unissent
les hommes de loi et la télévision
faut dire qu'il y a des avocats par
exemple qui sont très tôt dans la dans
la médiatisation je pense que quelqu'un
comme Gilbert Collard c'est quelqu'un
qui va très vite lorsqu'il a lorsqu'il
reprend un dossier ou lorsqu'il prend un
dossier très vite va mobiliser les
médias va il le fait souvent de manière
extrêmement
tonitruante le Canard Enchaîné l'avocat
todique alors si l'avocat est bon s'il a
appris quand elle est on peut délivrer
un message pas deux
le faire dans un langage concret
si possible en utilisant des figures de
style qui frappent comme l'oxymore
l'opposition de terme contradictoires
comme le soleil noir de la mélancolie
il peut être très efficace
un avocat qui ne serait pas communiqué
il faut qu'il change de métier donc s'il
arrive à convaincre son métier de
convaincre donc par définition pour il
doit convaincre des juges donc quand
même des journalistes c'est encore plus
simple donc effectivement la parole est
facile et puis en plus comme on dit dans
notre jargon ce sont de bons clients
parce que parce qu'un avocat il va il va
avoir le sens de la formule il va vous
il va vous en une petite phrase il va
vous rendre une atmosphère et va vous
présenter un dossier va vous présenter
son client donc c'est formidable voilà
c'est espérons que la Société générale
ne va pas continuer à cacher des
éléments l'instruction n'a pas été faite
à charge et à décharge les avocats ont
vite compris qu'ils n'avaient que
quelques secondes pour avoir une chance
de passer au 20 heures au journal
télévisé après vous devez le résumer en
une minute trente une minute 40 2
minutes donc la phrase que vous allez
prendre de l'avocat c'est pas seulement
le bonbon s'il y a un bon mot dedans
tant mieux mais avant tout la phrase
sera celle qui va le mieux expliquer les
choses le mieux faire le balancier entre
la défense et le et l'accusation par
exemple et c'est ça ce qu'on va aller
chercher en priorité c'est un monde de
fou
on est en train de on est en train de se
déconnecter du champ classique de la
liberté d'expression comment voulez-vous
exprimer librement intelligemment une
opinion en six secondes oui je le fais
parce que je peux pas faire autrement
pour un jeune avocat réagir dans
l'urgence n'est pas chose facile
Thibault de montbrillal en a fait
l'apprentissage en 1998 pendant le Tour
de France
cette année-là il est plongé dans une
tempête médiatique liée au scandale du
dopage de l'équipe Festina cadre de
l'équipe jusque là numéro 1 il est alors
le défenseur de Bruno Roussel directeur
sportif de l'équipe de Richard Virenque
mise en examen Russell finira par passer
aux aveux et reconnaître l'utilisation
de produits dopants au sein de son
équipe
pour attaquer de l'heure d'être un
communicants tout en maîtrisant le code
pénal
donc il a changé de position et comme je
savais que ces aveux allaient avoir des
cons des conséquences en chaîne terrible
j'ai eu l'intuition qu'il était
essentiel de cadrer la comme et donc de
faire un communiqué avec lui et on a
travaillé au mot près un communiqué que
j'ai ensuite été lire devant la meute et
ce communiqué a cadrer les aveux de
Bruxelles tels que je souhaitais qu'il
le soit par la presse l'objectif était
d'optimiser les performances
sous strict contrôle médical afin
d'absolument essentiel dès lors qu'on
fait le choix stratégique de communiquer
d'essayer d'imposer la base de la
communication vous êtes dans l'action et
pas dans la réaction
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'actualité judiciaire
racontée comme un feuilleton elle
transforme parfois les marches du palais
en plateau télé
l'interdiction des caméras dans les
salles d'audience oblige les
journalistes à recueillir les
informations à la sortie des prétoirs
et lors de procès très médiatisés se
pose la question de la sérénité des
débats nous avons deux procès le procès
à l'intérieur du prétoire qui parfois
semble ne plus intéresser grand monde
n’être qu'un prétexte à débat à cet
autre débat qui se passe en dehors des
murs et où se déroule une confrontation
de points de vue que j'appellerai une
sorte de procès médiatique le procès à
l'extérieur est souvent extrêmement
agaçant parce que parce que vous avez
une mise en scène notamment que ce soit
d'ailleurs de l'avocat de l'avocat de la
défense avocat de la partie civile qui
est une une mise en scène qui ne
correspond pas la réalité de l'audience
des ils vont expliquer qu'ils ont marqué
des points ce qui est quand même souvent
pas forcément la réalité telle que vous
l'avez perçue ils vont reconstruire le
procès à l'extérieur et c'est vrai que
je pense que ça donne une vision très
fausse c'est
résultat d'une société
hyper médiatisée c'est le résultat de
cette volonté de tout savoir de rendre
tout public l'avocat peut s'exprimer si
à mon sens si défend une personne qui
est attaquée à justement dans les médias
c'est même à lui de le faire
mais il faut pas développer un procès
parallèle qui doit avoir lieu dans le
prétoire qui est un des derniers lieux
le tribunal avec une audience publique
on peut s'expliquer
contradictoirement les deux parties
étant là donc ce qu'on dit c'est
toujours dissout contrôle de l'autre qui
vous accuse pour moi c'est un vrai enjeu
de démocratie le procès
en quête dirige pourtant que la petite
phrase à la sortie du prétoire remette
en cause un verdict
Omar radar vient d'être condamné à 18
ans de réclusion criminelle pour le
meurtre de Ghislaine Marchal à l'issue
de l'audience son avocat maître Vergès
dénonce avec virulence ce jugement
devant la presse on vous lit la décision
et vous dit c'est pas possible je ne
mets pas
mais je n'aime pas il faut aller acheter
l'opinion
les gens sont là avec le micro
on fait précipite il faut des phrases
chocs qui touchent l'opinion tout de
suite et je vais dire il y a un siècle
on a condamné un innocent parce qu'il
était un innocent un capitaine parce
qu'il était juif aujourd'hui on condamne
un jardinier parce qu'il a le tort
d'être maghrébin et là le débat va
partir de certains bons m’approuver
d'autres approuver mais le débat aura
lieu et la suite du débat c'est une
mesure de grâce
petite phrase grande conséquences en
1998 une grâce partielle permet à Omar
Raddad de sortir de prison après cette
année de détention
avocats se démarquent nettement de ces
stratégies médiatiques
comme Henri Leclerc 54 années de
barreaux au compteur et défenseur
acharné des droits de l'homme
un avocat célèbre mais discret dans de
grands pensées importants et très
médiatisés je suis resté silencieux du
début à la fin du procès c'est aussi une
façon de communiquer
mais qui ne plaît pas beaucoup au
journaliste je dois vous le dire je
m'interroge toujours je me pose cette
question et je la pose d'ailleurs
directement journaliste qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez m'apporter moi je sais ce
que vous attendez de moi je sais ce que
quel est votre intérêt nous n'avons pas
le même intérêt vous avez un intérêt
j'en ai un autre et je ne réponds à vos
questions que dans la mesure où vous
pouvez m'apporter quelque chose
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'avocat et le journaliste une relation
souvent ambiguë mais parfois une réelle
amitié et surtout une cause commune à
défendre comme dans l'histoire convaincu
Henri Leclerc et Lionel du roi unis dans
la recherche de la vérité allié au nom
de l'innocence d'un homme injustement
accusé d'un crime audio rappelle des
faits
le 26 juillet 1988 Céline s'étend et
retrouver violée et tué à la mode du
Caire village des
Alpes-de-Haute-Provence son corps mutilé
et découvert dissimulé sous un taillis à
environ 1 km du Café de la Poste tenu
par son père
très vite on arrête d'abord Didier
gentil un marginal de 29 ans surnommé le
tatoué qui avoue le viol mais affirme
que c'est son complice qui a tué Richard
roman 33 ans ingénieur agronome surnommé
l'Indien parce que lui aussi a un côté
considéré comme marginal vivant dans une
ferme en ruine dans la montagne il élève
des chèvres romain à vous d'abord puis
se rétracte
pour l'opinion publique Richard roman
est un coupable idéal mettre en ville au
clair son avocat est très vite convaincu
de son innocence
lorsque je dirais en cours d'instruction
au bout d'un certain temps dans une
déclaration que mon client est innocent
et la presse même ne veut pas longtemps
c'est extraordinaire comme je parle j'ai
des amis journalistes quand à ce
moment-là je leur dis écoutez je peux
pas continuer à dire des choses comme ça
il me croit pas ils disent c'est
l'avocat qui qui
[Musique]
va pourtant trouver un allié en la
personne de Lionel du roi à l'époque il
est grand reporter à l'événement du
jeudi
qui à vous et charge l'autre alors que
dit j'ai vraiment la conviction que
Richard et innocent on est pris dans un
piège infernal on a toute la presse
contre nous et les gens sont aveuglés
par l'horreur du crime et Henri pense
qu'il arrivera pas à s'en sortir et en
fait ce que je comprends ce qui me
demande
c'est de d'aller là-bas à la mode du
Caire et d'enquêter de refaire toute
l'enquête tout le dossier
[Musique]
quelques jours avant la parution de
l'article dans un climat délétère une
reconstitution du crime est organisée au
village l'atmosphère est électrique les
avocats de la défense et de la partie
civile arrivent au bar où doit débuter
la reconstitution je serai servi quand
même dans l'affaire roman par les médias
le jour où dans le village
des
gens du village et la famille se
livreront à mon égard et à l'égard des
autres avocats qui étaient là à des
violences
Henri Leclerc va bien malgré lui se
retrouver à la une de tous les JT
Richard roman est blessé ses vêtements
sont arrachés
donc les violences dont je suis victime
à ce moment-là deviennent un fait qui
est un fait qui devient en fait
médiatique c'est extrêmement choquant
vous en avez les larmes aux yeux quand
vous voyez ça parce que les gens qui
sont là qui sont pas des gens méchants
ni malhonnêtes ils sont persuadés quand
ils Leclerc est complice d'un assassin
et il essaie d'innocenter un assassin
reçoit un coup violent la diffusion des
images de l'avocat agressé scandalise la
presse le monde judiciaire mais surtout
le grand public c'est le début d'un
retournement de l'opinion
la parution quelques jours plus tard de
l'enquête de Lionel du roi viendra
mettre un doute définitif sur la
culpabilité de Richard roman
on commence à avoir des premiers papiers
qui disent que tout ça n'est pas
verrouillé que quand même il y a
énormément de doute dans ce dossier etc
donc à partir de ce moment-là à partir
du moment où on introduit le doute je
pense qu'on a commencé à gagner la
partie après quatre longues années de
détention Richard roman est enfin
innocenté Didier gentil et le seul
coupable du meurtre de la petite Céline
20 ans plus tard à vous rattraper
régulièrement comme si elle avait marqué
d'une manière
et puis j'ai reçu mais c'est juste avant
que vous veniez c'est vraiment un hasard
j'ai reçu il y a quatre jours une lettre
de la maman de de Richard
cher Lionel du roi chers journaliste
préféré ce petit mot pour vous dire
combien j'ai été surprise et heureuse de
vous voir à la télé il y a 8 jours grâce
à vous on a pu sortir de cette affreuse
à faire où la méchanceté contre Richard
nous avait embarqué et grâce à Henri
Leclerc également je ne l'oublie surtout
pas
Richard roman est décédé en juin 2008 il
avait 49 ans
Richard repose dans le cimetière
d'origine du village de ma famille c'est
en plus un coin ravissant et je le sens
tellement mieux dans cette paix voilà un
peu de passer qui vous fait coucou et
qui vous rappelle à notre amitié et
souvenir je vous embrasse
[Musique]
l'homme de l'oie et l'homme de presse
une collaboration exceptionnelle qui a
réussi à venir à bout d'une grave erreur
judiciaire
[Applaudissements]
Jacques Vergès de tous les avocats
médiatiques voici le plus grand ces
combats politiques son goût de la
provocation et du mystère ont bâti sa
réputation
un maître international en stratégie de
communication de la guerre d'Algérie à
Klause Barbie en passant par Carlos ou
Paul pot il fascine
médiatisation absolue en 2007 le
cinéaste Barbet Schroeder Brax sa caméra
sur ce personnage énigmatique
je voudrais faire un film sur vous mais
je voudrais être seul responsable des
témoins seule responsable des documents
et seuls responsables du montage
et j'ai dit oui
de toute évidence il voulait me piéger
et de te dire j'ai pensé que c'est moi
qui le piégerait parce que s'il fait un
film sur moi je devrais apparaître dans
ce film
et les gens verront que je n'ai pas de
petites cordes sur le front et une
langue bifide il ne jugeront d'après mes
paroles ils n'ont pas d'après les
paroles qu'on me prête et effectivement
je conseille à tout le monde de voir le
film
parce que dans le film j'apparais tel
que je suis
je crois humain
[Musique]
une carrière qui démarre ici en 1957 au
tribunal d'Alger et déjà un goût
immodéré pour les petites phrases
assassines quand les gens crient le
chinois
dire monsieur le Président devrait-je
dire à ces gens que pendant que leurs
ancêtres bouffés des glands dans la
forêt les biens construisaient des
palais
l'avocat épouse la cause
anticholonialiste du FLN des combattants
qui revendiquent l'indépendance de
l'Algérie c'est là que Jacques Verget
s'invente un système de défense qui le
rendra célèbre le procès de rupture car
je ferais partie du groupe des jeunes
avocats désignés pour la défense des
prisonniers du FLN nous allons jouer à
fond sur cette médiatisation
dans nos plaies de riz qui en apparence
s'adresse aux jeunes adressons en fait à
la presse c'est ce que j'ai appelé le
procès de rupture c'est un procès où
l'accusé se réclame de valeur qui ne
sont pas celles des juges autrement dit
l'accusé devient l'accusateur du pouvoir
en place c'est l'accusé qui dit je suis
algérien et le juge qui dit vous êtes
français l'accusé qui dit de FLN est une
organisation de résistance et le jeudi
est une association de malfaiteurs aucun
dialogue n'est possible
défendre l'indéfendable une ligne qu'il
s'est toujours fixée en plaidant la
cause de terroristes et de dictateurs à
travers le monde son fait d'armes le
plus célèbre la défense du nazi Klaus
Barbie pour un procès historique à haute
tension est ouverte
je demande au service d'ordre
d'introduire l'accusé s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
un tournant dans sa carrière Vergès
devient l'avocat du diable
je ne cherche pas l'unanimité je ne
cherche pas le consensus je ne sers pas
la pensée unique je fais ce que j'estime
en tant qu'avocat de voir faire un homme
est poursuivre les motifs les plus
graves son procès va nous permettre de
jeter un coup d'œil sur une situation
dans l'histoire de France extrêmement
importante je vais accepter lorsqu'il a
décidé de défendre Barbie après avoir
été l'avocat du FLN
il vient nous dire il vient dire à la
justice française vous êtes magistrat
aujourd'hui vous allez juger Barbie mais
vous étiez déjà magistrat sous Vichy et
vous juger les résistances à ce
moment-là il est en train de rappeler à
la France d'où elle vient ils étaient
pas tous résistants en France lui il
était pendant la guerre de 39-45 il
était il était un des rares des postures
qui agacent ces adversaires d'autant
plus qu'à chaque nouveau procès c'est
provocations attirent les télévisions du
monde entier un jour un journaliste me
disait
pour vous aimez les affaires médiatiques
et je lui répondais pour les meilleures
raisons du monde puisque les médias s'y
intéressent
et en effet les affaires qui intéressent
les médias qui intéressent l'avocat ce
sont des affaires qui posent un problème
de société qui intéresse tout le monde
vous n'allez pas faire une affaire
médiatique pour une querelle absolument
absurde dans un village entre un épicier
et un client qui n'a pas payé sa
consommation de café
il manquait à Jacques Vergès une
dernière expérience pour jouer avec le
public à 85 ans l'avocat passe du
barreau aux planches
serial plaideur un texte écrit et
interprété par le maître en personne
un monologue en forme de testament
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous vous demandez peut-être si la place
d'un avocat est au théâtre ou au palais
de justice si encore plus à l'aise que
devant un tribunal parce que dans un
tribunal il y a trois personnes
elles ont lieu le dossier elles ont déjà
leurs idées toutes faites quand vous
plaidez et vous avez à défaire ces idées
là et ce soir sur la scène du Théâtre de
la Madeleine deux heures durant l'homme
de l'oie est venu plaider ses causes
mais nous avocat nous cannibalisons nos
clients alors je prends son courage à
l'autre ça l'acheter alors je prends sa
vertu à l'autre son vice je peux alors
regarder le monde mieux qu'avec mes deux
seuls pauvres yeux un monde de double de
l'heure et de miroirs où ma vie se
confond enfin avec celle de tous les
hommes
standing ovation pour un homme
aujourd'hui reconnu comme un très grand
avocat mais aussi une figure médiatique
datant révolu qui incarne le souvenir
d'une splendeur judiciaire
[Applaudissements]
avec l'avènement d'Internet les cartes
de la médiatisation sont redistribués et
c'est une nouvelle génération de
défenseurs qui voit le jour voici Maître
Éolas derrière ce pseudo l'un des hommes
les plus médiatiques du barreau de Paris
médiatique et pourtant anonyme sur le
net plus de 15000 afficionados visite
chaque jour son blog le journal d'un
avocat le net un lieu de libre-parents
le plus connu de France quand j'ai
ouvert ce blog au début je pensais que
je culminerai à quelques centaines de
lecteurs par jour ce qui serait déjà en
forme de discussion très agréable mais
je ne m'attendais absolument pas à ce
que ça prenne de telles proportions je
ne voulais pas en faire un endroit pour
me faire de la pub pour faire la
promotion de mon activité
professionnelle c'était véritablement en
dehors
alors blog ou pub officiellement la loi
interdit aux avocats comme au médecin de
faire de la publicité avec Internet
espace difficile à contrôler la question
préoccupe de plus en plus le Conseil de
l'Ordre
sur le terrain de la publicité nous
sommes en train de créer notre doctrine
le public s'il tape avocat et qu'il
tombe sur maître x maître x finalement
va devenir l'incarnation de l'avocat ce
qui est tout de même bien excessif
quelle que soit les qualités de ce
confrère
tapez avocat sur un moteur de recherche
et vous êtes aussitôt dirigé vers des
cabinets très identifiés
[Musique]
bien loin de ce que l'on peut voir tous
les jours sur les écrans américains
un système totalement dérégulé où les
hommes de l'oie drague la clientèle sans
aucun état d'âme
formidable
le fait qu'un avocat se vendent comme on
vend un produit commercial
me choque en France heureusement ce
genre de spot fait encore rire
la publicité pour les autres aviendra
les avocats se vendront comme une marque
de lessive je pense que le plus de
clients c'est celui qui gagne le plus
d'affaires
il n'y a pas de publicité non plus dans
la presse écrite il y a pas de petites
annonces etc il y a pas d'enquart
publicitaire donc pour un avocat
pénaliste qui doit trouver des clients
parmi des détenus qui sont en prison ou
parce que les gens ont des soucis
qu'est-ce qui existe comme moyen de se
faire connaître forcément la presse nous
sommes des agents de publicité pour les
avocats un avocat qui fait qui fait 30
secondes un ou 20h enfin voilà il a une
notoriété fantastique et il a surtout
une notoriété un endroit très précis
pour les avocats qui sont les prisons le
réservoir de clientèle des avocats il
est en prison donc plus on le voit à la
télé plus sa notoriété est grande et
plus possiblement il a des clients il a
de la clientèle moi jamais personne ne
m'a dit je vous ai vu dans tel journal
je vous désigne bien sûr mais évidemment
que ça contribue bien sûr ça c'est une
évidence la carrière d'un avocat en
particulier au pénal elle se fait aussi
grâce à la médiatisation
au-delà des JT ce sont les plateaux télé
qui offrent d'excellents moyens
d'occuper le terrain aux heures de
grande écoute
[Applaudissements]
Gilbert Collard l'avocat télégénique par
excellence il s'est bien souvent fait
rattraper par la loi du genre le
divertissement
parle de vous mais je vous avertis si
vous parlez trop parce que vous êtes
avocat hein bon c'est ce qui va vous
arriver [ __ ]
du soir
voilà allez dans n'importe quel dans
n'importe quelle émission
accepté un talk show je suis pas prêt à
faire ça je revendique le fait d'être un
avocat médiatique mais je veux pas être
un avocat médias fil veut dire que la
médiatisation pour la médiatisation
c'est quelque chose je suis pas je suis
pas prêt à faire n'importe quoi
[Musique]
certains revendiquent haut et fort leur
présence médiatique c'est le cas d'Eric
de Caumont incontournable dès lors qu'il
s'agit de défendre les automobilistes
sur son site impossible d’échapper à son
impressionnant curriculum télévision
accro à la télévision depuis 26 ans il
en a quasiment fait un deuxième métier
aujourd'hui il vient rejoindre dans les
studios de RTL sont vie et amis Julien
Courbet le grand défenseur des
consommateurs devant l’éternel c'est pas
moi qui ai eu la volonté de me dire il
me faut absolument des avocats j'aurais
pu prendre des responsables
d'associations mais ils sont venus ils
ont su s'emparer du média et ils ont su
ils nager comme un poisson dans l'eau et
voilà je suis intimement persuadé que
nous avons rendu à la profession un
service que des campagnes de publicité
qui coûtent des millions d'euros à la
profession ne peuvent pas réaliser de la
même façon certains disent ils se font
de la pub pour leur cabinet alors qu'ils
ont
avant qu'il vous réponde exclusivement
faire de la pub ça voudrait dire voici
maître de comment 24 rue planchant à
Paris horaires d'ouverture 9h 17h prie
pour deux affaires traitées ce que vous
entendez faire ça je reçois une invité
c'est comme celui qui a sorti du
tribunal maître comment ça s'est passé
et voilà qui est entouré de tous les
journalistes et qui en général regarde
bien où sont les caméra mon client dans
cette affaire là il se fait de la pub
celui qui passe au 20h il se fait de la
pub celui qui passe sur France Inter il
faisait la plus grande consultation
instantanée de France c'est parti pour
deux heures de direct avec pas moins de
3 avocats au micro chaque matin le chou
radiophonique rassemble 2 millions
d'auditeurs et bah plein de couture tous
ces concurrents très loin de la
solennité des tribunaux les affaires
sont traitées dans la bonne humeur
est-ce que c'est vraiment un Sandrine de
payer maître de comment en aucun cas
bonjour Sandrine en aucun cas
voilà Sandrine premier cas Sandrine une
auditrice se plaint d'un contrôle
technique invalidé pot de terre contre
pot de fer et gros de ficelle les
rigidités de l'administration française
sont souvent épinglées
aujourd'hui c'est carte grise de la
sous-préfecture est ouvert du lundi au
vendredi sauf le mercredi de 8h45 à
11h45 et de 13h à 15h30
vous pouvez rappeler
l'administration de Mesdames et
Messieurs l'affaire suivant est un grand
classique l'histoire de pension
alimentaire impayée
c'est au tour de mettre Noah covich de
déployer tout son savoir-faire sur un
ton péremptoire qui fait toujours un
tabac
il vous doit à ce jour 4400 euros qu'il
refuse de payer car il dit ne plus avoir
de ressources alors qu'il possède un
véhicule neuf il vous doit combien par
mois
d'accord alors mettre qu'on reproche à
ce monsieur est-ce que madame monsieur
voilà au lieu de prendre en charge et de
prendre ses responsabilités ce monsieur
se permet de ne rien régler il a des
enfants il doit les assumer Valérie nous
allons donc essayer de le joindre dans
quelques instants pour qu'il nous donne
en tout cas sa version des faits ce qui
me semble être la moindre des choses
quand on plaide aux assises qu'est-ce
qu'on fait on communique avec des jurés
on essaie de les convaincre
ça marche bien ces émissions parce que
d'abord ça fait pleurer dans les
chaumières puis surtout on est vachement
efficace parce que on diminue c'est
réglé alors que devant le tribunal
d'instance il faudrait deux ans et demi
pour que ce soit dans le meilleur des
cas dans le meilleur des cas donc toutes
les recettes sont là pour que ça marche
mais c'est d'un populisme
que je trouve absolument dégueulasse non
moi je trouve ça Gerber ils peuvent ils
peuvent me donner 10 millions de dollars
pour que j'aille
là je je refuse
cette image vulgarisée de l'avocat
continue à réunir les suffrages du grand
public Julien Courbet a voulu nous en
faire la démonstration
il est un peu passé vous tapez 2
attention il y a la télé c'est parti
vous votez on se retrouve juste après
ceci muni de zapette sont appelés à
juger leurs avocat fétiches
c'est un peu la Star Academy des avocats
oh là là
sors de Kobo vous êtes certifié ah merde
ça peut vous arriver remerciant maître
fait le dos maître dehors
mais loin des petites affaires du
quotidien les avocats utilisent aussi
les médias pour faire avancer des causes
plus nobles par exemple pouvoir assister
son client en garde à vue dès la
première heure en cette fin d'hiver 2010
l'occasion va se présenter pour eux de
porter ce combat sur la place publique
un représentant d'un syndicat de police
profère des accusations graves sur
l'intégrité des avocats l'offensive
démarre avec un tract assassin suivi
d'une intervention radiophonique du
numéro 2 du syndicat il est une
offensive marchande des avocats à
laquelle on assiste aujourd'hui j'ai
envie d'avocat de travail gratuitement
c'est pour une prestation tarifée qu'il
veut intervenir vous dites
choqué par les mots qui ont été utilisés
j'étais choqué parce que ces mots
étaient des mots faits pour blesser
c'était des mots qui étaient faits pour
ravaler la profession d'avocat justement
pour pour dire vous n'êtes que les
commerçants vous n'êtes que des gens qui
vont qui vendaient votre soupe le reste
où vous en foutez
choqué par l'attaque les avocats portent
plainte pour diffamation contre le
syndicat l'auteur des propos a réussi à
trouver un défenseur à la veille du
procès il règle sa stratégie de défense
avec Thibault de montbrillal ils vont
vouloir t'amener à la provocation
en garde à vue que vous n'êtes pas les
membres du syndicat de police que je
défends dans ce dossier était en
campagne électorale pour dans le cadre
des élections syndicales à la police
donc le le document de campagne dont on
parle c'était pas un document destiné au
grand public c'était un document destiné
à la population policière mais ça reste
quand même dans une cadre d'une
polémique qui à mon avis aurait pu
nécessiter et qu'on en discute
tranquillement dans un colloque dans un
débat télévisé enfin vous voyez il y
avait des tas d'autres enceintes
naturelles pour en discuter que le
tribunal
mais les avocats ne l'ont pas entendu de
cette oreille l'occasion est trop belle
de en réalité de ce procès celui de la
garde à vue
on attaque pas les avocats impunément
pour une petite affaire de diffamation
toute la presse est convoquée
l'artillerie lourde et de sortie pas
moins de cité nord du barreau sont des
péchés
seul contre tous Thibault de montbrillal
est dans une position inconfortable
et Corinne Dreyfus mythe présidente de
l'Association des avocats pénalistes
mais l'avocat en phase de ses
contradictions
conflit d'intérêt ou non d'association
c'est des défendre tous
c'est plus compliqué que ça apparemment
c'est plus compliqué que ça
le client s'est ouvert vous pouvez vous
asseoir
trois jours de débat plus tard
l'opération de communication est réussi
le policier Patrice Ribeiro est condamné
à un euro symbolique pour ses propos
diffamatoires mais surtout les avocats
auront réussi grâce aux médias à
informer le grand public sur les
conditions de la garde à vue mieux
encore le sujet est aujourd'hui entre
les mains du Conseil constitutionnel
[Applaudissements]
longtemps les barreaux ont formé le
vivier naturel du personnel politique
Gambetta ou Poincaré il y a un siècle
plus près de nous François Mitterrand ou
encore Nicolas Sarkozy tous furent
avocat mais depuis quelques années la
tendance est curieusement inversée
explications
[Musique]
de venir avocat à leur tour au début
c'était un étonnement amusé quel est ses
place à un étonnement tout court parce
que ça devient vraiment un effet de mode
l'un des tous premiers ça a été Noël
Mamère mais depuis c'est de plus en plus
d'hommes politiques avec même parfois
les cas les plus étonnants l'ancien
garde des Sceaux Rachida Dati qui a
demandé à prêter serment avec tout ce
qui est l'avait dit sur notre profession
ça nous a surpris et flatté bien sûr
parce que ça voulait dire qu'elle avait
enfin réalisé ses erreurs
Rachida Dati Noël mammaire Dominique de
Villepin Frédéric Lefebvre Jean-François
Copé François Baroin pour ne citer que
tous jeunes avocats les cabinets
recrutent ces nouveaux maîtres au carnet
d'adresses bien fournis ce sont des
métiers qui tous les deux sont des
métiers encore une fois d'exposition au
public ce sont des métiers qui ont
qui sont des métiers de pouvoir
qui sont des métiers de parole
qui sont des métiers de communication et
qui sont des métiers qui
ont aussi en commun la violence des
soirs de victoire et la violence des
soirs de défaite je pense que les
motivations de ces gens
sont double il y a ceux qui ont besoin
de trouver une activité accessible et
puis il y a ceux qui cherchent à
exploiter la notoriété acquise dans leur
activité politique les relations qu'ils
ont pu se faire et l'entregent qui que
ça que ça leur a procuré pour gagner de
l'argent et ça c'est tout à fait
méprisable si
l'avocature devient les Invalides
pour des ministres qui n'ont plus
la confiance de l'opinion
pourquoi pas mais alors là je voudrais
mettre en garde que cela ne soit pas
une occasion de faire du trafic
d'influence
de jouer dans carnet d'adresses
et ce qu'il faudrait que les politiques
après avoir terminé leur mandat leur
fonction face tout à coup au nom de je
ne sais quelle vertu comme s'il ne
connaissait personne et comme s'il
devenait
inutile à la société vous savez on a
l'habitude de trouver de la suspicion
partout je crois qu'il faut être plus
simple Noël Mamère a bien voulu répondre
à nos questions députés Verts ancien
journaliste de télévision il est inscrit
au barreau de Paris depuis 2008 mais à
vous une activité judiciaire bien mince
les procédés cas à trois plaidoiries
encore elles étaient bénévoles à la
demande
d'amis de confrères avocat je n'ai pas
monnayé mon carnet d'adresses et je ne
suis pas dans un grand cabinet
d'affaires et un cabinet dans lequel par
exemple qui a été chargé de préparer la
privatisation de GDF parlons clairement
vous pensez à Monsieur Jean-François
Copé je pense à lui oui mais je pense
pas qu'à lui il y a d'autres lui c'est
le plus voyant le plus obscène
[Musique]
péter ni Jean-François Copé ni Dominique
de Villepin n'ont voulu répondre à nos
questions
l'intégration au barreau de ces hommes
politiques fait toujours débat car il en
va de la crédibilité de la profession
d'avocat
moi j'aimerais bien une Dominique de
Villepin Rachida Dati au Noël ma mère
viennent plaider avec moi une affaire de
pédophilie
une affaire dans laquelle tous les mots
du serment de l'avocat prennent une
résonance
l'humanité
la dignité
ça reste quand même un monde de combat
judiciaire
c'est ça le plus important pour moi oui
sinon je ferai autre chose
sinon je ferai du lobbying
[Musique]